[Music]  in a town just like your town if your  town was a dream that's beautiful  live the grumpiest grouch the world has  ever seen  [Music]  you're mean one mr. Dripps  it was cut Liana can't just what's back  as an eel this degree and checkmate  again  [Music]  the mayor was Christmas to be three  times bigger this year for 53 years  Christmas has brought me nothing but  misery I become Santa Claus to steal  their Christmas sir if he could deliver  it in one night then I do steal it don't  that's hurtful this perfectly recreates  a mating call of the reindeer the home  oh hey there sorry little goat I was  calling for a rare  Wow  the Grinch is loudest snow I never heard  it my life what are you doing okay  [Applause]  [Music]